this kind of full circle moment here
because you kind of grew up like Star
Wars adjacent basically you're yeah it's
really awesome like it's as awesome as
you can imagine honestly
I grew up with like Star Wars figurines
around me at all times like that was the
gift that like George Lucas would like
give it Christmas and stuff like that
we've got all these awesome figurines
and so yeah my child who was just being
kind of surrounded with these characters
and the lore of these stories and then
when I was old enough I got to see the
movies and I was like all I was putting
all the pieces together so it's really I
feel like the relationship that I have
with it is it feels really organic and
sort of simultaneously like very
sentimental and and magical and so um it
was just such an incredible privilege to
get to work on this I screamed when they
announced your name oh thank you thank
you thank you can you talk about cuz I
mean I've heard so much about it being
such a collaborative environment what
was it like for you kind of coming in
and getting to make your episode you're
all yeah so that's that's what I was so
surprised by because you know especially
in TV you're you can be kind of almost
like a soldier you know it's like it's
like okay we're just moving we're going
it's very fast and you know we need you
to do this this is and then get out and
that wasn't the case at all John brought
all of us in all the filmmakers in
really early really allowed us to take
ownership over the pages that he and
Dave Palani wrote and and then just was
an incredible support like was a huge
guide and and yeah just like what
wouldn't let you fail kind of you know
not to say that that is not it within
the realm of possibility but it was like
you really felt that you really felt
like you had a code
they're like you had someone there who
was rooting for you every single second
amazing and lastly someone else that's
in the Star Wars universe by the way
Laura Dern
coming to Jurassic how excited are you
to have those OGS on its I've known for
a little while and it's been really hard
like if you like look back at interviews
and people asked me and I like you just
like see me being like yeah it's
happening it's just I mean it's it's
it's it's just it's the ultimate you
know it's I am so incredibly excited
Laura and in particular and very excited
about and I also happen to know her a
bit and she's we directed a project not
together but she did one segment I did
another segment a few years back and so
she's just someone that I respect
you